Gavin Nome is either the devil incarnate
or being used by the devil we have the
receipts we have the best threeyear
record of any modern American presidency
American people support what Biden has
done he's such a fing liar he's planning
to uh run when they take out Joe Biden
but here he is saying that he won't do
that and their mind would want to run
when you have someone of such esteem as
our incumbent president of the United
States with a record of accomplishments
and a man of character a man of decency
I'm old school talk about loyalty I'll
I'll go to ends of the Earth for this
guy I'm old school talk about loyalty
didn't he cheat on his wife with his
chief of staff I think that was what it
was right yeah yeah yeah